Peter let's get right to it then cuz
this segment is devoted to some of the
things you've heard and learned at the
Scouting Combine you had the 30 nuggets
which was a compelling read on Monday
morning notwithstanding the fact that
one of the nuggets was devoted to the
nuggets that Christopher put into a
trash can one week ago today in
Indianapolis but other than other than
writing about Chris's
food poisoning and or stomach bug give
me some of the big takeaways you got
starting with the players were always
interested in as they enter the draft
the quarterbacks yeah Mike every year is
since the NFL has allowed it at the
Scouting Combine
I have tried to go to the quarterback
throwing sessions just because I don't
know these guys I don't watch much
college football at all in the fall so I
went to the throwing session on Thursday
night at the combine and what really
really impressed me was Jalen Hurd's
first of all I thought that he was
basically kind of a runner who's an okay
quarterback and and and I thought he
threw the ball really well the people at
that workout the NFL people who I talked
to just in a random survey in the
hallways on you know on Friday
afterwards really liked what they saw in
Jalen Hertz that's number one number two
I think it's really really interesting
right now to see the disparity of
opinion in Jordan love right now because
the Utah State quarterback I think is
one of these guys he could go sixth in
this draft
he could go 26th and there are concerns
about him off field he got arrested for
marijuana which was later dropped that
charge was dropped right before the Utah
State ball game in other words what does
he do and putting himself in that
position getting ready for the draft
but his arm and his ability to make
plays on the run I think really is
something that turns on NFL people right
now and finally you know when you talk
about guys who have been up and down the
spectrum in terms of opinion
I'd say Justin Herbert really fits that
bill he was the star of the Senior Bowl
and he
came in here he met with the Patriots he
had a good meeting with josh mcdaniels
and really was impressed with that and i
think that who knows what that means
we'll see but I do think that it's gonna
be an interesting contest right now to
see whether it is Justin Herbert or
Jordan Love who gets all the love coming
out of this combine because both of
those guys could and I emphasize could
be top 10 picks okay all right Peter I
mean that's that's great stuff and the
first one I want to ask you about is
just Jalen Hertz all right Jalen Hertz
you know I'm intrigued by the player the
specimen you know I you know you he
plays the position of quarterback you
know well he's a good athlete I'm not
blown away by his throwing I need some
work there you know dude what do you get
a sense or did you get a sense from
teams about does are they gonna just try
to make them full-fledged quarterback
will they try to make them pay some Hill
maybe and have them do stuff like that
well that's a good point Chris um that
is a really good question and what to me
was very interesting is that two
different teams said to me that is the
way he threw that post corner route
right which is really kind of a staple
of what they want to see from
quarterbacks there they said first of
all not a lot of movement in the
football a good spiral thrown pretty
much on target right you know forty
forty five yards down the field right I
think teams like that and look I believe
right now that he could end up being at
least early on at a some Hill type
player but I do think he's gonna be
he'll go no later than like say mid
third and if depending on who really
wants him if some team takes him that as
a veteran quarterback he could do that
for a couple of years and be in position
as Taysom Hill is in New Orleans to be
the starter opening day 2021 and this is
gonna be a strange year for quarterbacks
in the draft we focused a lot on guys
like Joe burrow to Otunga bi-lo adjust
and Herbert to a somewhat lesser extent
but we've got this crazy musical chairs
game that's going to be played in free
agent
see it's going to impact for some of
these guys who otherwise might have a
shot to play sooner rather than later
there may not be a seat for them you are
gonna have to accept for a lot of these
guys the reality that you know unlike
the trend we've seen in recent years
where if you're a first round
quarterback more likely not you're
starting at some point your rookie year
a lot of these guys going to be sitting
watching and learning and maybe that's
better for some of these guys to not get
thrust into the fray right away because
with each young quarterback who thrives
right away it raises the bar and if you
don't thrive right away you may be run
out of the game yeah yeah well you're
right about that like you you got to be
careful and know your know your player
your quarterback your draftee whatever
he may be and have a good feel for one
where your own team is can you support
that top ten quarterback pick and make
him succeed and put the good pieces
around him to get that era off on the
right foot and then too you got to know
where your quarterback is you know NFL
football schematics knowledge wise
maturity wise is he gonna be handy you
know be able to handle all the other
things that come along with playing
quarterback in the NFL you know they
listen here we are a year after the last
draft or not quite a year yet but you
know we've heard a lot of rumors about
Dwayne Hoskins not you know crossing the
T's and dot in the eyes and maybe not
totally being all in early on in his
rookie season and you know a little
complaints about work ethic there so
those are things that you certainly got
to take into account but as far as when
you're gonna thrust them into this
situation next one I want to ask about
Peter Peter Justin ur Burt right I mean
the talent to me and again I haven't
studied like deep dive yet but of course
has great size we saw great physical
ability at the combine we saw a really
high end difficult throws that he made
look like it was like you know just a
walk in the park you know he does it
very easily one of the negatives you
hear about Justin Herbert because I feel
like he's a little bit polarizing to the
national media some love them some hate
them what do you hear from coaches
behind the scenes about him
you know well Chris he's a little bit
plotting in the pocket well if you
watched him on Thursday night you saw
that he's not one of these guys who's
really really quick getting back and and
especially obviously if you have to take
the snap from center that could be a
factor but but I think a lot of people
in the NFL really like the fact that he
went out of his comfort zone you know
and went to mobile and was the best
player on either team right in that week
and and and I think that's one of the
things that impressed him
I talked to Herbert on Sunday and one of
the things he said is he's not going to
mobile and going to Indianapolis and
going to these places is important
because obviously he's a kid from Eugene
Oregon who went to high school in Eugene
who went to college in Eugene
he's never been off the west coast and
this really was a good thing I mean it
sounds ridiculous in this day and age
that a college football player would be
they'd be wondering how is he gonna
handle it when he when he leaves home
right mean it sounds silly yeah but I do
think there's a little bit of concern
about that and I'll tell you this I had
one team basically say to me that they
think he'd be a great match with the
Chargers because he probably needs to
work for a while to get acclimated to
the pro game
the Chargers look like at least
preliminarily right that they would like
to play Tyrod Taylor Yeah right for much
or most if not all of this year while
they groom a quarterback unless
obviously they go out and get Tom Brady
but they're not gonna go this is a draft
and develop team the Los Angeles
chargers and that is where a guy like
Justin Herbert in my opinion would be
best suited to go not exactly the way to
develop the fan base in LA but that's a
different issue and the thing about
Justin Herbert that stands out to me
he's six foot six and one very
accomplished head coach's opinion
resonates through my brain anytime
there's a quarterback taller than 65 no
Parcells hates tall quarterbacks and
Peter it may be that plotting that
you're talking about that is a factor
Chris you know a thing or two about
Parcells from how your dad had to deal
with them but I
six six six seven and I think uh-oh the
Big Tuna thinks he's too big I think
that's a legit question Mike I do
especially this day and age in the NFL
right now where quarterback movement is
so key and that's what I think's
intriguing about herbart because yeah he
is long and you know long-limbed and
tall out there but unlike a lot of the
you know 6 6 plus quarterbacks we've
seen that have come into the NFL
Herbert's a little different in the fact
that he's an incredibly explosive
athlete you know the ones that I think
of like Mike Glennon and you know Ryan
Mallett and like you know there's Brock
Osweiler Brock Osweiler all right they
couldn't they couldn't you know get out
of their own shadow they couldn't get
out of their own way
Justin Herbert's a little different as
we saw I mean you know the vertical leap
you saw the 40 he's got some twitch to
him but I would agree you know those are
that would be one like on the field
that'd be one of the things that does
concern me is he plotting is he too long
is he twitchy enough to hop around the
pocket and make a quick explosive throw
you know just all the sudden and then
the one thing I continue to hear and I'm
just glad to hear Peter that you heard
it as well as yeah I do find it crazy
but I understand it that yet teams look
at him a little bit like he you know
Mike and I talked about it like he's
Bubble Boy like he hasn't been out of
Eugene Oregon and there seems to be a
concern about whether or how he'll
handle life in the new city and and and
not in his little comfort zone president
of the Joey Harrington fan club Peter we
asked him
we asked him who he admired growing up
and he said Joey Harrington we found a
Joey Harrington fan
well join join he can join with Matt
Millen then not here's the one thing
about here's the one thing about size
okay
he's one inch taller than Peyton Manning
yeah he's six pounds heavier than Peyton
Manning I just look yeah bleeded 67
percent of his passes last year and you
know one of the problems that
traditionally if you look at the really
tall quarterbacks you know one of the
problems you go back and look at Dan
McGuire now that was a different error
in NFL history obviously but he just
wasn't an accurate passer and
and look he has had Herbert has had some
problems with accuracy
he was like 59 his junior year but in my
opinion he really improved his game in
2019 right he was better more consistent
in 2019 look I don't know where he's
gonna go
beauty with quarterbacks is always in
the eye of the beholder
and so I don't know who's gonna pick him
I don't know who's gonna take him but I
would much rather if I were a team
looking at the quarterback for the long
haul this is a guy I'd want to study a
lot just because I think he has shown
the tendencies he's extremely smart yep
he's shown the tendencies right now to
be the guy who I think long-term has a
chance to be good in the NFL yeah I'm
with you
leader he's got a lot of top and talent
I think his ceiling I could argue would
be as hot and again I haven't studied
yet I know this is but I his ceiling to
me looks like it could be higher than
anybody in the draft now whether he you
know obtains his full potential and does
all that we'll see but there's a lot to
be intrigued by by his physical ability
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports